well hello there rejects Greg Alba
Donald Humphrey
we're gonna watch Polar Express John
yeah people pay good money to watch
these videos you better deliver better
comedies that I'll get more topical this
is progressed past 2004 this is the Mads
Mikkelsen action film or something love
action and Mads because a lot of people
have been asking for this before we go
into this I wanted to say a huge huge
thank you to everyone who has been
following us over at our patreon page
there's some things that we want to
start adding in and around February time
for a patreon but right now well we
currently have that a lot of people are
loving our weekly Q&A s we do TV show
reaction of watcher Long's for shows
like my hero academia Full Metal
Alchemist Brotherhood attack on Titan
supernatural Gotham and Riverdale and
John does music video coverage as well
got plenty of reward tiers but the most
sincerest thanks to everyone who has
been following that's currently anywho
let's get to it
and we'll do a patron of the day shout
out for JT at the end of this video
[Music]
John way yes yes John Whitmore
[Music]
[Music]
Big Boss
[Music]
Wow that's an efficient gun right here
very
[Music]
Thanks
whoa doing a good thing
[Music]
all right
Netflix January something tells me it's
gonna get even more personal when
Vanessa Hudgens gets kidnapped or
something all and then he's gonna have
to save her some even though he probably
is insisted multiple times he has no
actual attachment or care for her he's
gonna find out that he does care this
movie is one of those films that
strictly hinges on execution more than
anything else this story has been done a
gajillion billion times named a hundred
movies it looks cool though it looks
really cool for me I'm a simple guy when
it comes to movies like this I'm not
looking for crazy new story per se it's
like when I saw when I saw John wick
trailers I was like yeah this looks like
you know I've seen this movie before
yeah and then you watch it you're like
wow it's actually really unique the same
thing goes here I'm actually intrigued
because it's based on a graphic novel I
think by Dark Horse I feel like I can
actually squeeze in a graphic novel
reading than it is to catch up on
decades of comic books in order to keep
up with a movie a little bit Mads
Mikkelsen looks cool it's like obviously
he's gonna be believable in this role I
like he's like this combination of John
wick meets snake especially the end when
he's got the big like lazy Gatling
like it really does look like John wick
with like those elements of something
like something of its zany or like a
smokin aces or something yeah the
colorful characters and stuff equalizer
yeah
retired hitman who wants to leave a
quiet secluded life now is forced out of
an Iron Man as a young hit manner one is
money and then you'll
have this relationship that I'm like am
I gonna care about Vanessa Hudgens in
this movie a lot of times they they do
that where you're like oh this is part
of his grounded relationship you know
though the life outside good something
like that as it stands though there was
some cool bone crunching action Mads
Mikkelsen does look very believable in
this role similar to how John wick
introduced this world of the Continental
which brought a unique element to it
I like this set up they're trying to
kill him because he's retired and if
they kill him they get his like I don't
know eight million dollars in investment
money goes back to the company or
something's you can't retire that's just
a problem waiting to happen because the
second you retire they're like okay
who's gonna kill me or you know unless
you're planning on just dying in the
field dying doing what you do they mean
that's the only logical explanation I
could possibly conclude as to why you
would stick around yeah and I like the
music in this trailer a lot I also in
terms of its cinematography I really
like it's sort of European aesthetic and
the way it's all captured it feels like
a European film like if someone told me
this was a foreign film even though it's
all in English I probably would have
believed it yeah that Sensibility and I
think to Jonas åkerlund has done a lot
of music videos and stuff like that and
you can definitely get that sense from
like the pop and the colors and some of
the energy like it doesn't look like
it's gonna do that the entire movie
which I hope it doesn't and appreciate
but it looks like when it goes crazier
when it wants to go stylized it's really
gonna do that and one thing that made me
curious is that you have Mads Mikkelsen
and Vanessa Hudgens seemingly at the
center of this but like the supporting
cast like they're I caught like a number
of like comedic phases like Matt Lucas
who's like the guy in the big yellow
suit I mostly know that guy from like
wacky character in Hamid he's like
Little Britain and stuff like that and
then you got like johnny Knoxville and
stuff like that and so I'm wondering if
this movie might be a bit like zanier or
more out there than this trailer wants
to communicate because this trailer is
mostly going with like the John wick
yeah and a heaviness of it which can
sometimes lend this trailer to feeling a
little bit cheesy but I think you bring
up a good point with the fact that
there's comedic actors in here I do get
the vibe that this movie will probably
have more
then the trailers leading us to believe
ya cuz right now is selling us like
equalizer John wick yeah but I don't
think it's only going to be that you
know yeah it looks like it wants to have
that like and being basically trying to
get that market yes when you get that
market why why but I being based on a
graphic novel to like it makes a lot of
sense especially you look at all the
character designs and everyone specific
and everything is colorful and everybody
has their own color palette this looks
like it could be more zany and more out
there than it wants to make us blue it's
probably gonna get Zane II and it's like
fun and games part of the first half of
act 2 when all the hitmen are coming
after him you get all the different
kinds of younger hitmen and this girl
from this country and this dude from
this country uh is special see you know
it's gonna be fun
it's literally for a January Netflix
film fun action it looks pretty exciting
because yes words it's a point action
yeah
and like I said everybody and their mom
loves mats because this is just like a
gift for everybody and it's like what if
John wick star demands alright guys well
are you excited for the Polar Express I
can't believe I just I came up with that
it's a good joke I came up with a [ __ ]
was one of mine before we wrap this up I
wanted to give it patron today shout out
to a handsome gentleman a beautiful man
with a heart of gold and the balls the
size of an avalanche JT JT is a man who
has been part of our patreon for so long
he's been a loyal follower a loyal
patronage act he actually told me
recently that he's planning on starting
up a twitch channel and a YouTube
channel he wants to do a little bit of
gaming I think he said possibly reviews
mainly gaming stuff so I'm excited for
you buddy I know that you can be a
little bit shy a little bit introverted
but now's your time to break out of your
shell because if there's one thing that
we learn from being on YouTube for so
long is that if you're shy and break out
of your shell women just come crawling
at you man left and right it's
ridiculous I get hit up so much at least
five times in the last four years
oh wow that's almost it's more than one
year more
then my whole life prior to YouTube
that's 1.25 strange woman liking me and
their always healthy and they'll they're
they're very committal definitely they
take things slow and gradually so get
ready your life is gonna change for good
oh yeah guys it's gonna be the polar
opposite from where you're right now
guys can subscribe to the reject nation
click that notification bell ring it
whatever idiots say and check us out on
patreon we got stuff we talked about at
the beginning of this video a wig